basis of battum chair
in that the majority of the interventions
to night and this topic
consumer and corruption
pro staff and describe the beginning of
this debate
let me just
file
dans ie de member of parliament present
in the room but i'm sure she will be
watching das carefully van roofvis
show was in finding the european union
to finance om concrete products in the
middle east and challenge and sympathy
kilo the case of iraq just  just is an ex
empel
just de take the numbers just for the
rock specific lee who i am financing
konkrete projects and that means the
mining der least job creation that people
who could study
process work hisses and therefore the
coolest stuff is that level had a level
of application on the ground and ensures
a mobile effe seriously wel summer
disclosures refinance in the middle east
just for iraq in the last die is one
point of twenty five trillion  us of
concrete project
just for rock this to say that this is
not just diploma's the window
diploma c in this particular time of
global polytex
is a variable elements and sometimes a
billy boy underestimate the power of our
diplomatic en gate met maar it's not
just the  promise
it's also about supporting barry
concrete lead process that helps to keep the
databases people many of us at its real
people it real people
children women men der feijst
difficultés snap folio stand for the
great and not leave in which difficult
situations and security temse nam  i
home
the european union and the remaining
institution sawyer financing of soul
delonghi produce a literally
sevink projet for medium of people
and he think we should what we that i
regret this one possessed expensive on you and
pan with needed so often and after
invite you  to document you yourself
preferably under protest
you agree of financing in december is
eng this would be a service to the way
in which repre  sents a
york was also is harry said let me
see clearly that will succumb that
sign we not be appropriate for new to
indicate we offer next
commission and the nexttime percent it
has position of on this is all before
them to show wit te  save the chances
prevent me said they on ihop love you
that the european union and the video support
their hearts be even more so in the future
of fundamental partner for the people of
the region thick sometimes i don't
realize how important it  is their only
play one ever you visit you hear from
your interlocutors not only de gave him
a kind of decisions but the people
series society simple citizens from the
key democracy
that ik santeras and some times has
impression that their own eyes and roll
much more than  do european i
think the red skin wants hard to be
investing just as nice a boat economy
diplomatic barosso security at home in
supporting the
this region in finding the sweat to
sustainable peace  and sustainable
seafood and though his way as many of
you set and d66 in the start with the
first
rejection of any form of violence and
disproportionate response and action
that we see the photos of that car ride this
is clearly unacceptable and this is exact
noise for instance  in iraq how jarring
spirit in the securité sector reform hisses
and knuckles we are not in for a
reform otherwise the war and be in
beijing and that we do not respect a
micro's mission the to change and in
taste the way in which
these jeans can handle  this shed that
solutions of the country can handle with
care physicians and many yes so
saw and he hopes this parliament wants
that evolution port to a new and
further engage mine
and word of the european union's
institutions in the middle east
thank you man from libya in  the good sense
of national nimitz aan de witzier tumor
chompy you are on a absolutely not us
would say come debate and